here's where I've begun I draw I drew
myself a Cartesian plane and the reason
why I did that to begin with is I start
to as I go through this I start to gain
information and knowledge about the
graph and I want to put it on to the
Cartesian plane as I go so that's kind
of like it's a little bit like um they
say good chefs say when you're cooking
you should clean up as you go so that at
the end you don't just have like a dog's
breakfast like literally adult referees
you're like oh man where do I start
right so so what I'm trying to do is as
I find something out I'm going to put it
straight on to the graph I stream to the
Cartesian plane and then I can somewhat
sort of put it to one sign in my brain I
don't have to keep remembering it I'm
like I have I have that information it's
represented visually okay so at the
moment I only have a single piece of
information that's on the Cartesian
plane that is a single piece of mission
about my parabola what piece of
information do I have there right now
I've got the y-intercept it's negative
five and we got that from saying if you
let X equal zero right you get y equals
zero plus zero take away 5 which is
negative five and we kind of established
that so we're good okay that's the
y-intercept a steezy pot then it comes
to the x-intercept now when I look at
this and I'm like oh yeah that pair of
numbers that add to 5 and multiplies to
minus 5 I can't think of what that pair
of numbers is immediately so I'm like
don't have time for this I'm gonna go
straight to the formula ok that's kind
of what it's for
by the way fun fact sometimes the pair
of numbers you can think of it just
takes you too long and so when you go
through this you go through the whole
process you end up being able to
simplify things out you're like oh they
are whole numbers after all I just
didn't think of them okay and that's
that's ok but this is what I get now can
you just
fact-check for me did I do the quadratic
formula correctly are there any errors
in it are you okay with it do you see
how I've done it I've also done things
like I mean depending on how you wrote
it I've seen students for example
they'll write the first step as 25 plus
20 is that correct
25 plus 20
I could ask you to vote again I could 25
plus 20 will give you the same thing at
the bottom that I get right but can you
see why I have not done that okay
because if I'm asking you to check my
work or more importantly if I'm checking
my own work I want to be able to look at
a line that shows me where did that plus
20 come from right it came from this
double negative it came from this four
and this one and this five I know where
it's coming from you know where it's
come from as well you can kind of read
my brain you you can see I was doing the
- for a second okay so you can't end
them with this answer are you content
with this answer no sorry you're not
content with that answer what needs to
be plus or minus so so there is a plus
or minus I've wrote a pretty small but
they're tucked away in the middle okay
so hold on a second
let me ask this I am gonna ask you to
vote thumbs up thumbs down who's not not
tough who's happy who's content with
this answer thinks this is perfect
thumbs up for yes thumbs down for no I
don't I don't like it thumbs up
now now commit to something man what is
that is that down okay it's just like an
angled down okay
thumbs up just a way for yep okay okay
I'm still waiting for some commitment
over here is that it down that's it down
okay okay I can't really we're quite
split here oh okay thank your hands down
alright it's Shawn you're pretty happy
with this team tell me about that
so Sean said a few things here I wonder
if we can
some people like food or like your
median said so you said the first thing
was you said we got two values out of
this do we get two values that it is we
do right the next thing you said is Sean
was we've got an x and y out of it do we
get a Nixon way out of it
we don't actually because look at the
way the equations started or the way the
formula started right it started with x
equals so actually the two values have
got are both they're both exhale use
which is kind of what I wanted because
I'm searching for X intercepts I've
already got the one self okay okay so
you said you were happy though because
we've got two answers and I'm okay with
that
who else said they were happy with her
we had a few thumbs up didn't we who
else is who else was happy with it well
you're all I'm happy with oh wow okay
mine works that bad okay we think you
did English standard we don't like your
answers okay fine that's the way exactly
what do you think okay you got you go to
a calculator I'm gonna come back to that
in a minute
Rastan Alex what are you thinking I will
get that we will all get there okay yeah
what do you think huh okay so this is
interesting you said a few things there
right you said don't we have to solve
this
hold on ice we're all part of this
together right you need to be part of
this too we have to solve this further
now I'm interested by that like the
would solve it generally means like
finding instances right I have as DeSean
mentioned I have two answers here but
you're suggesting I need to know more
about these answers I'm just gonna park
that thought someone said I think I was
over in this corner someone said this is
okay but not for graphing is it yeah
okay you're happy to take ownership of
that
why why don't you like my answers for
graphing cuz you all said my working was
fine think about where it's always once
there's the square you know like yep the
square root of five
yep yeah yeah okay so we yep yep okay I
wanna move because I don't know if we
all caught that right so you said you
said you said a word that no one else
has said yet which was if you put this
in decimal right
now I haven't been talking about
decimals or factories or anything and
I'm intrigued that's the place we go
because like you said you don't know
where these things are you don't know
what these numbers are and I'm supposed
to put these onto a graph right now
therein lies the issue sometimes we've
done this a few times right sometimes
we'll say hey draw something just to
help you work something out
right so it's kind of like a stepping
stone it's a means to an end right right
now the graph is not a means to an end
right now the graph is the end that's
the thing I'm focusing on I can't just
do like a rough version of this I need
to do it properly that's the actual
answer I'm producing for that reason I
need to know where these things actually
are I don't I mean square root of five
is about one point no sorry two point
two or something like that right right I
need des because it's not it's not a
nicely a fraction right so can someone
go ahead actually all of you we got two
answers here right
some of you can you pop in your
calculator minus 5 minus 3 root 5 divide
the whole thing by 2 and then can I get
I know you already have the answers and
then the other half can you do the plus
for me okay just let me give you a
minute and if some of you already had
the answer which is great but I'm
looking for two answers some of you do
the minus - um you do the plus one
okay we got some answers okay Perrin
John you go ahead can you give me the
minus one the first one you okay and
that was all the decimal points you
wrote yep
and then I've got another one what's the
other one 0.85 four six nine - oh okay
sir so now this begs a question this
begs a question right there are three
decimal places here there are 10 decimal
places here okay which which one do you
want to use this is more accurate this
one's less accurate okay I do need both
values right so at them I'm going to
just focus you on the level of
approximation what do you think thank
you so I don't let you
Zack yo come to you debrief on it but
this is probably the instrument you're
using probably or something comparable
to it to draw your graph right now I
don't know about you but if it's there I
can't see the ten decimal places of
accuracy that are on this right so it's
kind of like cool but I can't use most
of them in fact depending on what your
graph looks like I can't even use these
two I would suggest all right can I
round it up can I just say just
personally I'm just gonna we could do
this for a long time but just personally
what I would write here what I would
write here is probably - 5.9 or 0.9 but
I probably can't draw any more accurate
on to my graph than that so I'm okay
with that level of detail